and on the topic of legal exposure for
the president we turn to cbs news legal
analyst ricky clement councillor good
morning to you a lot to talk about here
let's start with mitch mcconnell's
comments he says the president is
morally and practically responsible
for the events of january 6. how might
he be criminally responsible as well
well mitch mcconnell certainly invited
the new attorney general once he has
confirmed that is merrick garland
to go forth held an investigation and
decide whether or not he would
prosecute by the way for those of us who
watched every minute of the impeachment
proceedings even donald trump's own
lawyer said
well we shouldn't be here in impeachment
there always is a remedy
in the criminal courts but what we have
to see here tony is this is not simply a
legal calculus it is a political
calculus
does merrick garland as the newly
installed attorney general once he
is want to go after a former president
have to remember before the election joe
biden was not necessarily in favor
of going after a former political
opponent
because it hurts democracy now the
calculus may have changed politically
but then you get to the legal issues and
you have a big
first amendment defense in a criminal
court
why would there be a first amendment
defense given that the president not
only on the day of january 6 but leading
up to it
spread this large lie that there was
fraud in the election i mean
people defend this country the military
defends this country
for that very issue defending democracy
defending freedom if the president
lifted that up why wouldn't that be a
direct line
to incitement i think what you have is
the exact same
argument only in a different courtroom
which would be the criminal court
in washington dc and what would happen
here is very different than what
happened in impeachment
you do have a first amendment offense
whether or not it is successful is
another matter
so you would wind up with motions to
dismiss if in fact there was a
prosecution
and a conviction you would wind up with
a series of appeals
it would ultimately have to be decided
before the u.s supreme court
do we look at as the impeachment manager
said the big lie
six months of activity about election
fraud
culminating in a speech leading to the
insurrection
acts of domestic terrorism or do we have
to look at speech alone
the legal scholars say this is a high
bar
and a tough case it seems like it should
be an easy case
but the law is not quite so simple very
interesting let's talk about the state
of georgia before you go
ricky there's a district attorney there
who is
investigating a case of potential
election interference
against donald trump what's the
likelihood there how did that work
i think this is the case to watch there
is a grand jury being empaneled for the
month of march
you have a new district attorney in
fulton county which encompasses
atlanta which would be a biden voting
block
and those would be the jurors you're
looking at
election fraud conspiracy to commit
election
interference the interference itself
these could be misdemeanors or felonies
you have a d.a who is unafraid
she has gone as far as going after
educators
with a ricoh charge that's called
racketeering
would she be afraid of doing that here i
don't know
we're looking at the president's actions
in words lindsey graham
as well as rudy giuliani and we haven't
even gotten to the state of new york
ricky kliman thank you very much we
appreciate it